[Music]
[Music]
my name is jerry gallagher master
leather craftsman and founder of leather
surgeons
today we have a black caviar chanel
classic flak jumbo bag
that's been severely damaged by an
incandescent light bulb we had this
customer reach out to us
she did a closet restoration actually
and
somehow an incandescent light pole from
a contractor burned its way
clear through her handbag through the
outer flap
through the lining but what i'm going to
try to do here is just
graft new leather over the damaged area
and preserve as much of the original
part of the bag as i possibly can
[Music]
i'm going to start by opening up all the
stitches around the front
flap of the back
[Music]
we're going to use a sewing all and a
really sharp knife
to be able to just you know get in
between the lining of the bag and the
shell of the bag without causing any
damage
i like to pull out the stitches one at a
time because eventually when we stitch
this bag back together we're gonna have
to stitch in the same exact holes that
the manufacturer stitched in the first
time
i'm going to open up the two gusset
tacks so that we could
access the interior lining of the bag
between the shell and the lining of the
bag
and see just how much we need to do as
far as replacing the internals
the burn went completely through the
outer shell and through the interior
lining of the bag
[Music]
for the most challenging part of this
job we have the damaged area in the
lower right quadrant
so it will be much easier for me to take
the front panel off and just recreate
the front panel
but what i like to do is preserve as
much of the front panel of the bag as i
possibly can and just replace the part
that's damaged
so i'm going to take my knife and i'm
going to very carefully skive off
which means cut away the existing
leather that's burned or damaged
[Music]
i'm going to make our little pattern and
i'm going to replace that piece of
leather
[Music]
i use a pattern to cut the size of the
front panel and make sure it's 100
[Music]
accurate
[Music]
because the bag was so severely damaged
and it was burned completely through
and actually clear through the interior
lining
i'm gonna cut fresh lining panels
we have patterns already pre-cut for
this particular bag
the interior lining of the bag is made
of goats so
we replace it with goat as far as chanel
this bag is chanel caviar leather
which we also stock we're able to
replace
everything about this bag exactly the
way it was done the first time
i'm going to take that piece of caviar
leather and i'm going to
hand skype it which means shave it down
[Music]
if i sky the leather paper thin and i
lay it right along that line
when i drop my new stitch over that seam
there'll be
a zero transition between what was there
before and what we have now
it should completely disappear
i'm going to lie and cement that piece
of leather
right over that seam this is a
traditional
leather contact cement so you need to
apply the cement to both surfaces
give it a minute or two to set and then
press the pieces together
[Music]
when you're doing a restoration and you
want to put the stitch back in the
stitch hole that was there before
you need to aim the needle for the hole
so when i
re-quilt this leather any stitches that
are visible i have to make sure i drop
the stitch in the same exact hole
it's just a question of measuring
everything out because
the flap quilting has to match the body
of the bag quilting
when you close that bag all of those
seams should line up
now we're going to unweave the leather
of the chain this customer felt that the
patina on the gold was starting to fade
a little bit
so we replayed the metal
then i'm going to re-weave that leather
through the chain
and stitch the two ends
[Music]
[Music]
i feel really good about what we did
here today we took a bag that would have
otherwise been trashed and we gave it a
new lease on life
you